on sunday pakistan will celebrate 75
years of its independence followed by
india on monday but behind these
celebrations like countless stories of
pain and tragedy arising from what is
known in the subcontinent as the
partition of india the border
determining this was finalized 75 years
ago today
these other lines a british lawyer sir
cyril ratcliffe drew across the map of
british india to create india and
pakistan pakistan itself divided into
east and west pakistan at that time
in creating hindu majority india and
islamic pakistan conditions were set for
mass migration and religious pogroms
some 12 million people found themselves
on the wrong side of a line that divided
nations along religious lines hindus in
newly created pakistan fled to india and
muslims in the opposite direction
up to a million people were massacred in
the ensuing violence
it's a story of shared violence among
pakistanis and indians as we head into
independence day celebrations of both
countries it's worth hearing from those
that witness these new nations being
born amidst the carnage as well as the
promise of a better future
i was
very young at that time i think i was
12 or 13 14.
so
i have all those harrowing
memories of partition
but not pretty was a very peaceful place
there was no this thing that
he is
a
what religion
my all friends were
muslim girls or sabdar girls then
suddenly
it's starting it
they started dividing us
my father used to teach in a village in
what is now the indian side
he had come home for the summer break
when all hell broke loose
countless dead bodies and injured people
arrived into my city which was on the
new border
i remember going there as a child to see
what was happening
one day
our neighbor
he came to
his place and said
that ah now you go
because there's the danger of your life
is when we came to delhi
we saw
a sentence lying here and near
there was also massacre my father's
business had gone
and we
we didn't have any money left it was
very difficult
i'll tell you
prepare to seek shelter within the
borders of pakistan
it's really difficult to talk about it
for those of us who remember it
i'm emotional right now because i
haven't spoken about that time in 75
years
i lost my
uncle i lost so many people during these
partition days
i feel very sad
that
this
hatred for each other why it has started
i see on my
ipad pakistan programs
and i love that language because i
belong to that place i love those people
the history of the world is full of
stories of war
but war solves nothing
you can fight as many wars as you like
but meaningful decisions are only made
at the negotiating table
it's only the
top leadership which makes us
fight with each other this is what i
feel but sunday
we should
become
together
yeah this is my innermost wish